[Music]
you are watching the press preview
a first look at what's on the front
pages as they arrive coming up we'll see
what's making the headlines
with polly mckenzie the chief executive
of the demos think tank
and chief political correspondent at the
daily telegraph christopher hope
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the daily mail leads with business
bosses mps and health experts
demanding boris johnson reform coveted
rules on
self-isolation before they crippled the
economy
downing street is refusing to be drawn
on whether social distancing rules
had been broken following michael gove's
announcement his marriage is over
reports
the daily telegraph the eye goes with
hopes of quarantine free foreign trips
to europe for those
who've had both doses of a coronavirus
vaccine
that's also on the front of the express
which says germany's leader angela
merkel backed down
on her plans to make british tourists
entering the eu
self-isolate after a showdown with boris
johnson
the times claims that fully vaccinated
people who've been in contact with
someone with covet
will be able to carry on life as normal
in a few weeks without the need to take
daily tests labor's battling spend
by-election win is on the front of the
guardian with the party's leader shakir
stamos saying kim ledbeter
won it for her campaign based on unity
and decency the yorkshire post has a
picture of kim
ledbeter giving her mother jean a hug
after winning the battle in spend by
election
the financial times reports that
london's share of the european market
has steadily risen in recent months
making it europe's largest share trading
center
england's euro 2020 clash with ukraine
makes the front
of the mirror with captain harry kane
promising to pull out
all the stops to win the match saying we
will give it
everything paul gascoigne says
england can win the euros if fans throw
all their support behind
manager gareth southgate that's in the
sun
and england's clash with ukraine is also
on the front
of the star
and we're joined tonight by polly
mckenzie the chief executive of the
demos think tank and chief political
correspondent
at the daily telegraph christopher hope
good evening to you both
let's start with the mail first of all
um
their headline there don't let nhs app
[ __ ] britain
um and it's really a cry for reform of
the self-isolation rules polly
yeah so i mean we're now huge numbers of
our population are vaccinated we're one
of the top countries
in the world in terms of vaccination and
that's had a huge impact
on the hospitalization rates so even
though case numbers are going up in a
really worrying way
the numbers of people in hospitals
actually still really low and that's
partly because
we've done really really well at
vaccinating the most vulnerable first
other countries have taken a more kind
of open and broad brush approach
and if people are still expected to
isolate it
time they kind of glanced most food
somebody who tests positive for covid
it perpetuates the disruption it means
we're not eating the benefit of those
factors
i defer to the epidemiologists on the
mass of this
we have to find a way to benefit from
that and we have to focus on managing
the hospitalization rate
and trying to target that and we want
people
come forward for those last vaccinations
including potentially for booster
vaccinations in the autumn that we might
all need
we have to give people an incentive um
you know basically that
i'm agreeing with the daily mail which
is
always the first of everything um but
christopher as they're saying
up to a million people every day could
be forced to isolate
because of the test and trace rules that
that's just simply isn't workable
perfectly healthy people
to be isolating like this yeah what
we're seeing is newspapers pricing in
the fact that the end of the pandemic
the lockdown
social the social distancing is going to
be on the 19th of july
so it's what happens next and the
problem here which there the mail are
correct to talk about and we're seeing
in schools and we'll come on to that
shortly
is that the nhs app if you're near
somebody who may have had been a ping
then you can be pinged yourself and it
can
literally send home entire workforces
certainly
most of us now work if we lucky enough
to work in office
work in an open plan office now this nhs
app
can literally send so many people home
as soon as we get back to work so it
could the
what the point here is this requirement
to go home and isolate
is going to [ __ ] britain if it's not
changed so
it's as we leave this uh this difficult
period
however the past 15 months it's how we
return back to normal
is is the point and we'll see more of
these stories over the next few days
boris johnson
only today saying how we're going to get
to stage four how we're going to
get out of this are these these
restrictions and so we look forward to
hearing what he's got to say
so this is the beginning i would say of
of
of a two-week cycle of stories can you
see any
alternative or is it simply scrapping
the the system completely
well we these figures appear to show we
have broken thank goodness
um the the the issue of um of people
catching a disease and and deaths and so
it looks like
it can be dealt with and is being dealt
with as the most
vulnerable of us have had there to jazz
i i've had my two jabs
i'm not sure what but you guys but i
think you know we have to learn to
live with it polly mentioned flu she's
completely right
i mean it looks like by the autumn we'll
be having one jab in each arm and back
to work
yes and polly let's talk about um those
that have had
both jabs incidentally i have had both
of mine as well christopher
i can join you in that um the idea that
that really
that the world really will open up to
those who have been double
vaccinated and that that's really what
the times is talking about it has been
dangled in front of us although not
confirmed
by the prime minister that those that
have had both jabs um
should be able to to travel
yeah i mean the crucial remember is it's
not up to us
i can't just tell france or germany or
that they're going to accept people if
they've been vaccinated
we have to then do some careful
diplomacy and persuade those countries
the value of those vaccinations and what
we know
is that whilst the vaccines are
very effective at reducing death
reducing sick
fees reducing hospitalizations and
reducing transmission
they don't stop you completely from
getting the disease and they don't
completely end
transmission so you know it's right to
carry on being cautious even about
people
had both my second one is on sunday so
i'm very envious of the both of you
uh but soon i i will be in the the
hallowed category
and and we have to give people that
incentive to both get
and stay vaccinated whilst not making it
sound like it's a complete brief rule
you know masks i hate masks i despise
them they're really annoying
but it for me like if we keep masks in
some circumstances
like that that's the least invasive the
least disruptive thing
and we know that it does help to
transmission
uh and chris the added complication um
to the the double jab scenario is those
under the age of
18 and how they factor into the picture
we don't know
exactly how that would work and also the
um
vaccines that were produced in india
they might not be accepted if we want to
travel
in in europe so um being double jabbed
isn't necessarily the the complete route
out
it's not the complete route but it
certainly is going a long way down the
journey isn't it
uh the times here is reporting almost an
answer to what the daily mail is saying
it's saying that the government wants to
free us up from having this 10-day
requirement
to self-isolate now i see in this
article at times
the first the first um clear blue water
possibly with other governments in
scotland and wales and the rest
in this country because i think the
government's going to go down to common
sense it's where they started when they
went into stage one
they said use your common sense if you
want to hug somebody um and i think it
looks here like here
on there's a meeting on monday of the
kobit operations committee a very
important one
um chair by michael gove normally and
they're likely to sign up
offer plan which will mean that the
fully vaccinated and vaccinated will be
advised
to take daily tests but not required to
do so um when they're self-isolating i
think that's
that's how it should be i think we all
know sadly we all know
the dangers of this virus we know how to
deal with it we are very informed
people and it's about time the
government stepped back
and helped us get on with their own
lives i think that's where boris johnson
is
certainly with sato javi coming in as as
the new health secretary will see more
of this i think
of people being taken people being urged
to take back control
of their lives whether whether polly
likes it or not
let's let's um go back to the the point
mentioned about schools in the
management of covered within schools and
in the telegraph the archbishop of york
is calling for an end to school bubbles
something which it seems the government
is of a mind to do but not moving
particularly quickly towards that end
polly
yeah so just like you know the workplace
chris is talking about
entire classes or sometimes entire year
groups can be taken out by a single
positive test and that's then disruptive
to
the school but crucially those kids who
are potentially losing
days or weeks of education there's
rumors going around that kids are
finding ways to fake positive tests so
that they can all play hooky
uh and even if that's only true in a few
cases
it does seem again potentially
a serious problem especially we're going
to take it through the autumn
you know there is a debate about whether
we should be vaccinating children
the idea that we shouldn't somehow put
children at risk vaccinations
in order just in order to protect other
people when they're not at risk from the
disease but actually
it's a fundamental part of the flu
vaccination as well we give lots of kids
flu vaccines
in order to break and and protect
elderly in the community so you know
there's all sorts of reasons why we give
vaccinations i think we should
be incredibly aggressive about
vaccinating children
uh in order to reduce the pool of
infections reduce the chance of variance
and make sure that kids can stay in
school as much as possible but
christopher it's quite quite an odd one
because although
parents are very happy to be vaccinated
themselves they do have a question mark
over whether they should actually allow
their children to be vaccinated it's
very curious because they
have allowed them to have other
vaccinations in the past why do you
think that is
me well i i i think this those of all
sorts of issues here because parents who
may not want to be vaccinated do they
have the right to stop their child being
vaccinated
will the state step in i think we
haven't even got there this sounds like
a very good think tank paper for polly
mckenzie's demos think tank
i've got to say i'm intrigued by what
polly was saying there
about um fake uh uh fake
test results being passed around schools
that sounds very interesting but like
fake id
so to get into a pub back in the old
days they're now faking
vaccinations to even go to the pub in
the first place and show their fake id
probably so it sounds quite grim for
i mean we all know how hard it has been
for children over the past few months um
and i think um
you know i think this uh campaign that
we're leading the telegraph this
campaign for children
is well overdue and it one hopes that by
september gavin williamson
will certainly be telling schools not to
be selling entire
year groups home if someone is pinged
yes many will be hoping for that polly
and christopher stay with us we are
going to take a break but coming up
he won it but on a very narrow margin so
what does
shakir stammer think of the battling
spent result we'll discuss that
after the break
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
we should protect our heritage
unfortunately it will become part of
azerbaijan
this monastery is under the protection
for now the next five years at least of
russian peacekeepers
i'm diana magni and i'm sky's russia
correspondent based here in moscow
[Music]
i witnessed the despair of the armenians
in nagorno-karabakh who were digging up
the soil of their dead relatives
it's armenians who've abandoned these
villages now
despite what their strategy is i'm not
sure but they have made
some arrests already today
they can't kill everyone they can't
shoot everyone
they can't arrest everybody
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
[Music]
i mean this clearly says i love hitler
are you saying that
doesn't say hitler
[Music]
russia insists that its military buildup
in the arctic is purely defensive
my name is fatima zinzilla the founder
of ikesta from kuwait where we face many
environmental
problems related to waste pollution the
frustration
and lack of information we are
collecting recyclables
from houses schools and businesses in
order to recycle
[Music]
exchange if you recycle to get a tree
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now still polly and
christopher welcome back to you both uh
let's start with the
yorkshire post in this uh section and
the picture there let's um
get that up showing kim ledbeter hugging
her
mother a victory hug they're describing
it as after a quite a
torrid campaign hasn't it been polly
yeah it has and of course kim ledbeter
is the sister of joe cox who was
so viciously murdered uh during the last
days of the brexit campaign
and you know i mean i salute her
courage more than anything you know if
my
sister had been murdered doing her would
i want to throw myself into
doing that job fighting to elect to do
that job but you know i mean
i honestly don't know how she had the
courage to do that i admire her enormous
and the campaign was unpleasant she was
abused in the street uh some of her
campaigners were attacked
it was a close bought campaign uh
galloway uh campaigning uh as well as
the conservative
kind of obviously very close
um you know i think it was as kierstarma
said will come onto it but
you know a victory for for dignity
because you know
some of that viciousness that was
directed against her because of her
sexuality or because of her views about
sexuality
was just not what we need in our
politics today yes then
the guardian as uh polly mentions
christopher secure stamina
hailing the the labour win as a victory
for decency
which it really was because she so
clearly is a decent person
a decent mp now elected um
and it was a such a grim a grim battle
there
um the way that with the way the back
the election was fought
um i think the conservatives missed a
trick here they lost out by 333 votes
because the labor the left vote was
split with george galloway taking away
8 000 or so votes um boris johnson may
be thinking tonight
if only he really had dealt firmly with
matt hancock last friday
instead of allowing him to stay on and
so the matter was closed and then just
dismissed it as a as a western bubble
issue and it wasn't
i think that may have made um damaged
the the the attempt to get labor um
across indeed christopher and apolly